We were discussing the,
in the broadest sense,
the development,
the emergence and the development of the Polis.
And uh,
specifically I had been telling you about Hanson's theory about the development
of the family farm and the individual who worked the family farm as a,
a critical element in that story.
Now that same individual who produced the economic wherewithal that would
support a independent individuals who are not nobleman,
who could conduct their lives,
you know,
autonomous way and who fought ultimately fought their way onto a governmental
bodies,
which allowed them to participate in the key decisions to political decisions
and all other decisions in the state that serve element of their character,
of their place in the world is the one I want to turn to today.
Their role as soldiers fighting for the common cause and that common cause.
Now being not an individual goal,
not a family goal,
but the goal of the entire civic community which was coming into being and I
suppose would have had to come into being in order to have this role,
fighting for ones Polis,
the style of warfare that emerges in this period.
Apparently for the first time is what we call the hoplite Phalanx.
And each half of that,
uh,
needs to be explained.
Hoplite comes from the Greek word hope,
pleat,
tastes and help lead.
[inaudible] is built around the word helped long,
which is the name of a kind of a shield that the entrant treatment.
And we are talking about an infantry formation here at the infantry men wore,
oh,
Carrie,
I should say it was you want to get out of your head the notion of a shield.
That's a little thing that you can move around with one hand like that real
easy.
That's not what it was.
It was a great round shield,
about three feet across.
Um,
and it,
it would wreck.
It had a kind of a,
let me step out here so that I can show you.
I'll be doing a lot of it.
You can hear me,
can't you back there that all right.
Um,
imagine,
uh,
around shield of the size I've talked about and one of the things that's
important,
this end of the shield,
the right and from my perspective has a grip on it.
But in the middle of the shield,
there's also a kind of a loose piece of leather Thong that you can put your arm
through so that the shield is resting in part on that script and on the grip
that you hold at this end.
You need to do that to be able to control a shield that's as big as that and as
heavy as that because it is,
may fundamentally have a heavy wood typically covered by leather,
sometimes with some bronze,
the bronze sheet across the front of it as well.
That it is a very heavy thing and it's very,
it will weigh you down after a while.
It's going to be really hard for you to maintain that grip on that thing all
through the course of a whole battle.
But that shield is the key.
This [inaudible],
which gives the name to the uh,
word hoplite hopefully taste which is hoplite phalanx means that these men,
each man carrying his hot blonde are lined up first of all in a line.
But that line is reproduced going back so that you end up with,
uh,
about,
well,
typically a typical Phalanx would have been eight men deep,
eight rows deep,
and that block of soldiers,
however long it is or is made up is called the Phalanx,
which is something like,
it means something originally something like a roller as because the,
the Phalanx would've looked if you were up on a hill somewhere watching it go by
as though something was rolling across the plane as the men went forward and
looking pretty formidable as that anything in its way would be mowed down in the
normal course of events.
So that's what we mean by the hoplite Phalanx,
a core of heavily armed infantry men in a solid block.
Okay.
When did this come into effect?
Remains you,
I'm going to start out today's talk by giving you what is,
has been the standard orthodox interpretation of how the hoplite Phalanx worked,
uh,
of which I think,
again,
Hanson is a given us the clearest and most useful account.
But as you know,
already from what you've read,
this has come into great dispute in recent years.
And I'll just say a little bit about the dispute before we get through today,
but what I'm giving you as the old fashioned traditional interpretation by that
view,
the Phalanx would have come into being somewhere between about 706 50 BC,
which is to say after the earliest police are in business,
uh,
and according to this interpretation,
you really have them growing up together.
Nobody could be exactly sure about how this process work.
One of the big arguments that is part of this story is did this development of
new way of fighting come about rather quickly over a matter of a few years or
did it stretch out over quite a long time?
The most extreme critics of the traditional point of view would say over
centuries that you don't get the full blown hoplite Phalanx that I will be
describing to you even into the,
until you get to the fifth century BC.
But as again,
let's,
let's take it in the traditional way.
So if you imagine this is growing up as the Polis comes into being,
let me describe what a hoplite was like and then try to describe what the
Phalanx was like and how they operated and what are some of the consequences of
their coming into being.
The hoplite himself is marked by,
first of all the shield and second of all if we,
as we continue to think about his defensive capacities,
he has a certain amount of armor to protect his body.
He has on top of his head a helmet made of bronze,
perhaps weighing about five pounds.
These are approximate.
They would have different from person to person to some degree a very important
element that he would have had a breast plate made of bronze,
perhaps as much as 40 pounds worth,
he would have snapped across his shins,
greaves,
sort of like the Shin Guards,
said a catcher in baseball wears also made of bronze.
The Shield itself,
as I told you,
it was made of a heavy wood covered by a leather or bronze sheet about three
feet across something in the neighborhood of 16 to 20 pounds worth of shield.
And gripped as I told you before.
So you want to think about this hoplite as a,
when he has everything on and when the shield is in place.
Again,
let me sort of try to demonstrate this.
He is,
he ought to be covered by some kind of defense from head to toe.
The top is this a helmet that comes up over his face and covers it pretty
totally.
It's um,
made of strong metal.
It's a,
it's got very thin slits to be able to see straight ahead,
cover it up.
Everything else is covered up a good one.
We'll cover some of your neck as well.
It's very hard to see very much and you can't see anywhere pretty much,
but straight ahead.
You shouldn't be able to hear very much either.
And um,
what else?
Uh,
I don't,
must have been,
must have been two delightful to breathe out of.
The thing,
although you're in your nose is free,
but it's covered by a nose piece.
So there's this guy with this helmet.
It must way I'm driving.
I always want to have the modern football helmets,
which are monstrous.
I'm so old.
We used to play with leather ones without a face mask.
Uh,
what do they weigh?
Guinea football players here.
I think they weigh a lot.
I mean I think they're very heavy in deed,
but I don't know how much they would anyway,
if you imagine sort of putting on a modern football helmet with that mask in
front of you,
you would begin to get an idea,
only begin to get an idea of what it was like to have that a bronze helmet on
your head.
So there,
there you are with that.
Then you remember you got shin guards down to your feet.
You have this breast plate now between your waist and your Shin Guard.
There's some very delicate territory and there's no
armor.
That's what your shield is for.
Your shield should cover that territory.
You want that shield up so that it pretty well meets your helmet.
So,
so it's going to be at a certain distance,
uh,
but it will also go down to where it needs to go down here.
If everything goes right,
your enemy won't be able to penetrate you.
But you should be aware that there are two places where you are relatively
vulnerable for openers and that is if somebody can come in above your shield,
your throat is going to be available to him.
And if somebody can come in under your shield,
then you're vulnerable area will be vulnerable indeed.
So those are places where you see people get wounded and killed.
If that can be done.
One of the very important thing to understand this defensive problem,
and this is one of the debatable issues,
uh,
between the old guard in the traditional interpretation,
I'm still giving you the traditional view.
If you imagine that your hoplite is standing with his left foot slightly
extended in front of his right and we'll see in a moment to pretty well has to
be in order to deal with the spear that he's grasping.
And if he's holding his shield as he must this far,
then he's got a half a shield sticking out in this direction so that he's pretty
well protected on the left side,
but he's got nothing protecting his right side.
If somebody can come at him from this side,
he is very vulnerable from there.
Now that's a very important point because why in the world would you give a
shield of the kind I am describing for a man to defend themselves?
If you imagine him standing by himself anywhere,
if you imagine him any distance from the rest of the guys fighting alongside of
him it.
This has been one of the major reasons for explaining the function of the
Phalanx is I will explain it to you.
What are you going to do about the vulnerability on this side?
Well,
the answer is it in the traditional view is not as that he was never meant to
stand by himself.
A hoplite only makes sense in a phalanx and a Phalanx.
Understood in this way only makes sense if you imagine very close order.
Basically.
Ideally,
the right side of my shield is being met by the left side of the shield of the
guy to my right so that we make a solid block of soldiers able to defend
ourselves and perfectly,
but really essentially quite well.
Obviously some of us are going to get killed,
some of us are going to go down and we'll cope with that and just a few minutes.
But if you think of us as a unit,
we have a way of maintaining our security,
our safety,
so long as we remain in the proper formation that I have been describing.
Let me talk about the offensive aspect of it.
The idea of going into battle is not merely to avoid being killed.
The purpose is to kill the other fellow.
How do you do it?
The hoplite has two weapons of which the most important by far is a,
um,
a pike I guess is what we would call it.
It's a spear that you don't throw.
It's a spear that you thrust and it has,
um,
it's got a bronze point,
which is the business end of the weapon.
It's length might be anywhere from six to eight feet in length.
I should,
I said a bronze,
but actually it was,
the tip was usually iron,
but it could be bronze as well.
In addition,
it had a but made also of bronze,
which could be a lethal weapon.
If I strike you in a vulnerable place with a stick that has a bronze but on it,
it could well kill you.
It would happen because the spirit itself was made of wood.
And that meant you can count on it often breaking in the midst of battle,
in which case if you have one end of it or the other,
you can still have a point that you can use to help yourself in the scrum that
is a hoplite phalanx that'll,
um,
and uh,
although I don't quite understand that I should say there's many things about
how the fighting went on,
which we can only attempt to imagine because we just don't have a films of
ancient hoplite battles.
I'm sorry to say we have people inventing them,
but,
uh,
even the ones that are invented aren't very helpful cause this is awfully hard
to know how they did what they did.
But I think we can imagine some part of it eat more easily than the other.
What I was going to say is that you could at least theoretically strike with
your spear in an overhand manner,
or you could strike with it in an underhand man.
And the only thing is,
I don't know how you'd do that under hand when you're in the middle of a
Phalanx,
but,
so I will be talking about the overhand stroke,
which I find that easier to grasp.
Um,
so
let's see if I can again,
give you some sense of what this is like.
You have a,
um,
here's a hoplite standing like this,
and when he comes into contact with the opposing army,
he will presumably striked down in this way.
There were other things that he can do.
His Shield,
in addition to being a defensive,
uh,
thing is also potentially an offensive weapon.
He can build you with that,
um,
uh,
a shield.
And if he's stronger than you are a better prepared or more balanced than you
are,
he could knock your shield out of your hand.
He could knock you back and open up a space.
He could knock you down.
And so you should imagine that there's at least one chance to give you a guy was
shot with the shield.
And after that you could just be using it as a something to press the other
fellow back.
And you would,
uh,
meanwhile be whacking away with this in the most simple picture that you can
have of how the hoplite would've conducted himself.
The other weapon was a short sword that he kept at his side,
which presumably he would not use so long as he had a spear,
which was a better weapon.
But if that broke,
if that wasn't available to him,
he could turn to a short sword,
which was a thrusting sort,
not like the Roman short sword,
which was double-edged and slashing.
You had a stick,
somebody with this,
uh,
hoplite Phalanx Sword.
Now that gives you the picture of the individual.
I hope you can get some sense of,
um,
what the Phalanx might be like.
But as I try to describe how the fighting really went,
I always find it necessary to ask for some audience participation so that you
can get some idea what it might have looked like in a very,
very limited way.
So I would like to ask for some volunteer hoplites.
The Greeks,
uh,
as far as I know,
did not allow anybody to be left handed in a phalanx.
Think about the problem.
Uh,
so,
but we don't care.
You can be a lefty.
Uh,
you,
um,
of course the Greeks only allowed men to fight in the Phalanx,
but we are much more elevated than that.
So could I ask any of you who have the courage to come forward and fight in my
Phalanx?
Nobody could just come,
come forward.
Yeah.
I think we got more room here.
Okay.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
That'll do.
All right.
Well,
good,
fine.
Why do I have the shorter people come towards me and the tall,
taller people go into the,
in the back?
I think just making that easier for us.
All right.
I like this line up next to each other.
I guess you'll do up here.
Come on up.
There you go.
Uh,
now,
right behind him and perfect order you guys,
biggest guys in the back.
Go ahead.
Good,
good.
I'm making this third row.
There's enough for a third row.
Are we all set back up?
Make sure you behind somebody directly behind someone.
We need.
How many we got up front for
that.
So we'll have a three in the back.
That'll be all right.
But you get right behind that guy.
You gotta be,
boy,
you've got to be lined up.
All right,
now get into your hoplites stance.
Left foot forward.
Okay.
Now when you're fighting,
if you're fortunate enough,
and the Greeks were sometimes fortunate enough to fight people who were not
hoplites.
Like when the Persians came at them,
they fought off the hoplites against non hoplites.
Boy,
that's a nice day for a hoplite.
The Persian infantry did not have heavy armor.
They did not have that kind of a shield.
They had wicker shields.
We have,
fortunately,
we have vase paintings that show us Persians for one thing.
They're not dressed like civilized people in a dress.
They're wearing pants.
But they're also,
their shields are made of wicker and they don't have that kind of a metal body
armor and all that stuff.
And so you could blow through that infantry like butter.
I'm probably never that easy,
but really you're just not going to lose.
And the truth of the matter is hoplites beat non hoplites in all battles that
are fought on flat land,
uh,
in uh,
that'll set the Greeks fighting.
Uh,
I was going to,
I just want to tell you about,
uh,
in Herat it,
he tells the tale about how,
how the fighting went versus the the Persians.
And here's the line.
He says once the Greeks go to war,
they choose the best and smoothest place to go down and have their battle on
that.
And that wasn't just because they sort of had an aesthetic pleasure in Nice flat
fields.
That's what you need for a failings because to maintain the integrity of the
hoplite line,
you can't have bumps and grooves and trees and rivers in the way it will break
things up.
So they do in fact seek such a field.
If you're,
if you're fighting a non hop light infantry crowd,
you're in great shape.
But what the Greek spent most of their time doing was fighting each other one
hoplite battle of Phalanx against another hoplite Phalanx.
So you have to imagine that this thing started with these guys back in their
camp and the other army back in it's camp and they both have to agree that they
want to have a battle for a battle to take place and they will have picked a
place that is flat where they can do what they're doing.
Usually the battle took place over some land that was uh,
being contested on a frontier and they would go down to that area and pick a
spot and there they would go and fight with one another.
So now the of the two armies aligned up.
Here's an interesting question.
How wide is the line going to be?
Well,
that's not an answer.
That is entirely at the,
uh,
disposal of the general because he's got two considerations that he has to worry
about.
One is he can't afford to have his hoplite line outflanked because if I can come
around and take care of this guy from this side,
he's engaged with a guy who's right opposite him,
I can just kill him.
No problem at all.
So he has gone to at least try to be equal with the guy who is furthest on this
side.
And same with the guy on the other side.
So that means he's got to open it.
He's got to make his line unless he comes up with some clever trick,
the same size as the guy,
as the other guy.
Well what typically the two armies aren't identically in identical in size.
So if you're going to try to be the same breadth across the field,
that's going to affect how deep you can be and depth as we shall see once we get
started fighting as relevant in ways that we need to work out.
But if at one Phalanx is 80 and the other Phalanx is 12 deep,
the 12 deep Phalanx has an advantage.
And so numbers count,
but it's not an easy one to one question.
Various issues will determine who comes out of the head.
Okay,
now
let's make this first battle I'm going to describe for you be as clear cut as we
can make it.
And it probably never was like that.
Let's imagine my army is the same size is there is precisely so that the line is
the same size on both sides and um,
and it's all there for Wilson to the same depth.
And so we'll just do this imaginary perfect battle
he's going to have at as the two armies approach each other.
I should make it clear they start out walking at a certain clip.
By the way,
it's critical that they should stay in formation.
Nobody should get ahead of anybody else.
How do you do that?
With rhythm and the A in subsequent armies and later in history used drums to
maintain that technique.
The Greeks did it by the playing of a flute like or oboe like instrument that
played a military tune that had you marching forward at the right pace.
That was very,
very important.
So you're marching forward at that pace.
But now as you get closer and closer to each other,
various items begin to affect your behavior.
One is I would think fear.
In fact,
I know fear.
Uh,
so what do you can't?
It's supposedly you feel like running.
Can you boys in the first row run anywhere?
You got seven guys behind it.
It's not even an option.
And that's a very important aspect of the failing.
That's not even an issue.
So if you're afraid,
what are you afraid of?
Well,
the other guy is got people I should have mentioned on the sidelines one way in
another shooting arrows at you,
throwing javelins at you,
things like that.
You want to get through that as fast as you can and engage with the enemy.
But there's another reason why you want to get there fastest because well,
by now you've gotten you,
I should've pointed out that a chant we,
we know that before you started out the battle that you're general gave you a
meal and he also gave you plenty of wine so that by the time you were in this
position,
you've had a few.
And there's,
I mean there's,
it is a science to that too,
is perhaps some of you know,
no you don't.
You know,
college students,
they have no science at all.
They just said pour the stuff down their throats with a goal of becoming drunk
as fast as they can.
That's barbaric in the technical sense.
I mean,
the Greeks didn't say Plato Symposium,
all of these guys are sitting around having a drinking party.
That's all they do all night.
But they also are talking and they're talking very well as a matter of fact.
And they are,
the goal of this conversation is,
or,
or this party rather symposium means by the way,
drinking together.
So they're drinking and they're talking.
And both of these are supposed to go on at the same time.
And here's the thing.
The idea is to drink as much as you can without passing out.
And at the end of Plato symposium,
everybody is out except for Socrates,
who looks around and says,
oh,
well no more conversation and everybody's asleep.
Off He goes.
And we know who won that one.
Why could they do that?
Well,
they weren't,
you know,
ignorant undergraduates,
but,
but beyond that,
they drank wine,
not those barbarian liquids that you drink.
And also they mixed that wine with water so that it shouldn't get them drunk too
fast.
Think about how the world has decayed since those days.
So anyway,
but the point is,
they've been put,
it still has its,
uh,
it's a alcoholic consequences.
And I like to think that the trick for these guys was to get to that level of
inebriation before it affects your nerves and your physical ability to act,
but it's worked on your brain to the point where you get to that,
that sort of what I like to think of that bar room,
uh,
militants whereby if a guy says,
what your past the peanuts,
you say,
Oh yeah,
I think to think that's the ideal hoplite mode.
So I think that's working on and they want to get at those.
So bees on the other side and they want to kill him,
that's their mood.
Well,
all of that is working on both sides.
And so then when they come together,
they come together in a truck.
You have to imagine they're moving along quicker than you would by walking so
that they will go bang and we can see what happens.
However,
there's one other variable that you want to be aware of and that is,
he knows he ought to be going straight ahead like that,
but he also knows that his right flank is open.
Well,
he would love to be fighting at the edge of the Grand Canyon.
So it has no worry about his right flank.
But he's out there in the middle of a field.
Now he knows that first step or to be like this,
right?
But he's only human.
So the first step is like this.
And so as the guy on the other end,
on that side,
so in fact,
as soon acidities tells us beautifully in book five,
when the two armies,
uh,
actually hit each other,
they have already made a slight turn to the right.
Everybody moves to the right.
These guys moved to the right.
Those guys moved to the right and they're,
they're smacking each other.
Something like that angle.
Okay,
so much for that.
Now here we go.
I'm coming at this guy and what I want to do,
if I can,
I want to kill him.
If I can't,
I want to knock them back because what I really need to do is to get him out of
the way.
Let me imagine.
I've been lucky enough to get you out of the way.
You're fighting him.
You can't even look at me,
but I can do that.
And no one by no means by no means,
but let's face it,
in order to kill you,
I had to earn the privilege by knocking him back.
Now,
let's imagine I've been very lucky and gotten you just get down on your knee,
right?
Right.
Imagine that she's very badly wounded or dead,
but she's out of it.
Now,
here's where the ball game can really be determined.
First of all,
let's let's consider the man behind her.
Is that you?
Yes.
Right now,
if you are standing there with your shoes,
by the way,
first three rows of a chance of hitting each other,
if did so,
he's banging away over somebody's head at the guy and the other side,
but
you see this guy in front of you has just been knocked down.
The blood is spurting out of her neck or site or whatever,
and and she's groaning down there on the thing.
What is your instinct?
What?
What's your instinct?
Tell me.
Get out of here.
They just killed this guy in front of me,
not coming after me.
I was thinking of that wonderful scene and how many have ever saw the,
uh,
the longest day,
that day.
There's wonderful scene with his German officer comes down,
he's in charge of the defensive,
uh,
arrangements there at Normandy.
He's in a bunker and he's reporting back to headquarters and it's dark and you
know,
and suddenly it's enough light and he sees the,
uh,
suddenly on the,
on the horizon is 5,000 ships.
The whole damn fleet is,
as he calls back and he says,
they're coming,
they're coming says,
well,
why?
He says,
how many says thousands of them.
in what direction?
He says,
oh,
for me to do that?
That's the way it looks to him.
So what,
that's what his tendency is,
but if he does that,
it's very bad news for his city.
What he has been trained to do,
what he knows he needs to do is to fight forward and somehow over step over her
step on her,
do whatever it has to do to fill this hole.
He's got to come forward and take the danger and take the blows and close the
line.
Because if not,
now I am in the situation where my guy next to me,
he's beating you up,
but I can now get her and I can step in here and the guy behind me can do the
same.
And so we can create a wedge in which we are doing the killing and they are
doing the falling.
And if enough of that happens after a while,
some sense of what's happening upfront quickly works its way to the back.
And there can be a moment there.
But there always is a moment in a hoplite battle with the guys in the back say,
oh we have lost this battle.
And so the guys in the back turn and run,
which is the only thing you can possibly do once you feel are Phalanx is broken.
We can't stand against them anymore.
And when you start running,
the only thing the guys who were left up front can do is run.
Now think of what it's like to run with this in your head.
Can you make much speed that way?
No.
And speed is what you want.
And so the big issue is this is what you must never do,
but this is what you gotta do.
If you're Phalanx is broken,
you got to drop your shield and run.
And then I'm on the winning side.
But I want to do is kill as many of these guys as I can.
However,
you know,
there's this great question of how far to the Greeks pursue in a hoplite battle
and facilities has an interesting passage in there in which he says something
that the Spartans win the battle of Man Tinea and,
uh,
two acidity says,
but they,
the Spartans did not pursue hot play.
The Spartans never pursue their enemies very far.
It's as though he's explaining,
giving an answer to a question that somebody that,
why didn't the Spartans do better in that battle too?
Which there could be many answers at the battle of [inaudible],
but it seems to as a much easier answer how basically the Greeks couldn't pursue
very hotly with infantry.
They don't want to throw their shields away.
They want to keep their shields.
So guys with shields are chasing guys without shields.
They're not going to chase him very far.
Now,
another issue that emerges in discussion of these kinds of battles is a
casualties.
For a long,
long time,
the general wisdom was there were not heavy casualties in hoplite battles,
uh,
people calculating on what I was just talking about.
But then,
uh,
an old Yalie took this course when he was very young.
Uh,
lady became an ancient Greek historian.
I took the wonderfully outlandish device of answering this question.
He simply took all the battles in Greek history that we have a record of in
which we know what the casualties were like and counted.
And he concluded you anybody can check because there they are.
That casualties could run as high as 15% at a hoplite battle.
Those,
that's a high casualty rate and many,
uh,
military unit will break if they have that many casualties.
And the,
actually what he finds is the winning side would lose about 5%.
uh,
the losing side would lose maybe as much as 15%.
And so,
um,
you get some idea,
but don't imagine that these were anything like bloodless or easy.
They were,
they were bloody.
Uh,
although the,
the actual amount would vary with the circumstances.
Now,
um,
you know,
the battle is over in a variety of ways.
One,
the enemy,
one guy ran away,
that's pretty good.
But for the Greeks it was very important that things should be really official.
There were,
and there's a lot of debate about what I'm going to say next.
There were protocols of fighting that were followed.
Some people want to have these be many and for them to be very binding.
Others want them to be very few and not very binding.
And that's an,
uh,
an argument one can get into,
but some things seem to be indisputable.
For instance,
if I say we won the battle,
I can prove that to you most of the time.
Why?
Because I now occupy the land that we fought on.
Therefore I can do what they did.
Take a stick,
bang it into the ground,
hang on.
That stick a captured helmet.
By the way,
please get it.
Thank you.
Um,
I'll captured helmet or a captured Courselets something that represents the
military equipment that the losers had.
The left on the field,
we hang it up that is called a trophy.
And the word trophy comes from the word that means to turn trefoil and it means
to,
um,
the reason that is this is the place you try to put it down to the place in the
battlefield where the enemy turned and ran and that we own that property.
Now we own their equipment and therefore we won the battle.
Another tangible way of understanding who won the battle and who didn't is we
winners because we own the field.
We can pick up the casualties,
take care of those who can be saved.
Barry,
the ones who have been killed,
we don't have to ask anybody's permission.
Burial is very critical.
If you remember from reading the Iliad,
the Odyssey,
um,
it is absolutely critical in the Greek religion that people be properly buried
because if they're not,
they're shade goes on through forever in misery and pain.
They cannot rest quietly and hades unless their body has been properly buried.
So you've got to do it.
The losing side must come to the winning side and they must ask permission to
pick up their dead and buried them.
Typically that is granted and they can then do it.
But what they of course humbling themselves by making the request and coming
down under the orders of the winters and taking their dead away and being
buried.
So it's very,
very clear who won and who lost big.
And that's,
I think it's very important point because Greek hoplite warfare,
which is the characteristic warfare of the Greeks from the eighth century on
into the fourth is,
um,
never loses its character as a kind of a game in which there are winners and
losers and the winners are given the prize and the losers don't get the prize.
It's a contest just like everything else in weak society.
And there's a tremendous amount of pride that goes into victory and a tremendous
amount of shame that goes into defeat.
But we said the same thing about the Homeric heroes,
didn't we?
And here's the difference.
They're not fighting for themselves.
They're not fighting for their families.
And only to a limited extent are they fighting for their personal glory there?
Clay Os they are fighting for their city and they will be honored by their city
in victory or even in if they perform very heroically.
And of course,
what about if they were very shameful?
What about if they run away?
I think I want to save the illustration of that one until we talk about Sparta
with tortillas tells us very,
very specifically how bad that is.
It's bad.
And so you have this tremendous continuity between the sort of the honor code
that was so dominant in the Homeric world,
which has now been shifted to the larger unit,
which is the Polis.
And if you can see all adult males fought who I should back up.
That's not quite true to I is an important point I didn't make,
not everybody gets to fight in the hoplite failings,
the town,
the city,
the Polis does not provide the fighters with their defensive armor.
They might,
sometimes they might give them their weapons,
but not to a defensive armor.
You can't find it as a hoplite.
In other words,
unless you can afford to pay for your equipment
and that x clues a goodly number of citizens who are too poor to fight in the
Phalanx,
this becomes a very,
very large issue because the notion that there should be a real connection
between citizenship in the full sense and military performance is totally a
Greek.
I mean the Greeks just totally accept that idea.
Actually later on at the end of the fourth century when Aristotle was writing
his politics,
he makes really a very clear connection as to the style of fighting and the kind
of constitution that you have.
He said very clearly if you have,
if you use cavalry as your major arm,
your state will be an aristocracy.
If you use hoplites,
your state will be what he calls a poly Taya,
a moderate regime.
If you use a navy,
your state will be a democracy in which the lower classes are dominant.
So that there's this real connection and that's the way they really thought
about it.
And so what we will see as the Polis is invented moving away from arrows to
cratic rule in the pre polis days or in the early polls days,
you will see a middling group of citizens who are according to this
interpretation,
Hanson's farmers who are also going to gain the political capacity to
participate in the town councils,
uh,
and who are the hoplites.
But it will exclude the poor who will not have political rights.
And most Greek states just as they never move beyond the hoplite style of
fighting,
never go beyond the,
uh,
oligarchical style of constitution,
which gives only hoplites political rights in the state.
Okay.
No stay there because who knows,
we might,
uh,
the 20 million other things I might've said,
but instead,
let me put,
uh,
give you the opportunity to ask questions that you would like to raise,
particularly if you want to ask about how they fought.
As long as we have a phalanx here,
we might as well use it if we need to.
Are there any questions?
Yeah.
What are they prominently farmers?
The answer is they damn near didn't.
That is,
you've got a very key point.
There was very little military training.
On the other hand,
you don't need very much think about it.
What are the skills?
What are the technicalities?
If the bat,
if I'm,
I'm the general,
right?
And so I say,
what do I say?
Chart.
Now we're engaging each other.
What do I say?
Fight harder.
Men.
Now we're in trouble and I don't run away.
There are no techniques,
there are no maneuvers.
There are no,
you can't do anything.
And so they didn't practice very much except one stretch,
stunning exception.
The Spartans,
they will not farmers as we shall see and therefore they spent their lives
practicing warfare paid off.
They usually one.
So the answer is,
uh,
basically that the,
the ordinary Greeks did not engage in very much practice.
Yes ma'am.
If they're all fighting in this half split style,
how do all of these great Greek military personas developed who are famed for
being such wonderful individual soldiers?
There's no real hand to hand one on one.
Well look,
there is nobody out there that you could see typically by the,
we don't have guys like that.
The guys who are famous are the generals who are get credit for putting together
a nice formation when it's not the simple one I've just given you.
I mean,
just to be a little bit more,
uh,
um,
playing about that famous battle of marathon.
I will tell you about it when we get there,
but one of its features is that because the Greeks were numerically badly
inferior to the Persians,
they had this problem of covering the line,
you know,
so instead they could have thinned out their entire Phalanx,
but that would have given the Persians a chance to break through anywhere and
everywhere.
And so what a,
uh,
who's my general [inaudible],
did,
was to make his wings heavier,
deeper,
and very dangerously thin in the middle.
It was a gamble.
The gamble was our wings will crush their wings and turn in on them from behind
then from the side and set them a running before they break through our middle.
And as a Wellington said at,
at Waterloo,
it was a damn near thing.
The Persians broke through the middle,
but just before that,
the Athenian wings crushed the Persian wings and set them running for their
ships.
So everybody says what a genius [inaudible] was.
Um,
similarly in,
in naval battles a domestically is that,
um,
Salmas,
uh,
comes up with a clever,
endless,
clever devices.
So you see what I'm driving at?
We know those guys.
You never really hear of Joe Blow who killed 34 guys in the Phalanx.
Oh,
they must've been some guys like that,
but you just don't hear about those felons.
Uh,
okay.
Any other questions?
Yeah,
when they had no spear
get it wrong.
Yeah,
they would use these bears must've broke like mad.
And so the thing to do with,
unless you have something else to do with,
you know,
go for you for your
wow.
Always.
Oh yes,
always.
And you never,
according to my understanding of this,
you never,
never want to be without your shield.
That means you never want to be away from your failings.
This is disputed.
This is exactly,
these are the grounds on which this new school,
uh,
one of the ways in which they argue otherwise.
I'll say a little bit about that.
When I get through with the Phalanx,
I just want to,
yeah.
What about projectiles?
Now,
these guys don't have any projectiles.
However,
there are light arm troops made up of those.
Too poor to be in the Phalanx who do use projectiles and the projectiles are
arrows,
uh,
um,
javelins or stones thrown by,
slings to trouble with them is none of them has any range.
Think about that for a moment.
Oh,
these are not.
Get Out of your mind,
Henry.
The fifth,
forget about lovage in court.
Don't have,
what are those men in Lincoln Green with their enormous long bows made out of
good English composite,
whatever,
who can fire the thing thousands of yards and penetrate and killed the f the the
French nobility.
How many have you seen,
uh,
Henry?
The fifth in the Lawrence Olivier version?
1945.
They've got this miserable modern one with the sort of Vietnam like conditions
that they have out there training all through the goddamn battle of Agincourt.
Great battle.
It's got to have sunshine,
blue skies.
Terrific.
Well nevermind.
Uh,
they had very poor,
they had very poor bows and arrows.
He didn't have the composite bow.
It didn't have much power.
Then would have had a hard time getting through the shields and it didn't have
any distance.
So,
but they were worth something because they did this.
Actually those guys would be useful.
Not so much hardly at all during the scrum of the Phalanxes but should one side
be retreating?
That's where they do car.
There'd be,
once you throw your shield,
when you're running,
any,
anybody who's got a weapon can take you out.
And that's when it would have happened.
Yeah.
Is it unlikely that someone like this fellow's name
no Chinese?
Uh,
no.
The archer.
Oh,
in the Elliot.
Well,
is it
people would actually been able to do anything like that?
Yes.
The question,
the Elliott shows has a various people who are very good archers who could kill
the other guy.
I would say it's,
I'm sure there they were bows and arrows
at that time,
but they did not yet have the kind of armor that they would have in this time.
So they would have been more vulnerable and you wouldn't have had to have such a
powerful ball.
Of course,
Paris,
uh,
isn't he the one who kills Achilles?
Right.
But Achilles of course you got them in the heel where he didn't have any armor.
Anything else?
Yeah,
yeah.
Ah,
very good.
Yes.
And that's a big argument that nobody has a good answer for.
It's a traditional answer is that these guys actually did press up against the
rows in front of them and that this provided a momentum that gave the front line
and advantage and beating the enemy,
facing them.
You can see all kinds of troubles.
Why didn't the guys in the middle of get crushed?
Uh,
you know,
I don't have any very good answers for that.
And yet it is.
One part of the traditional explanation is this,
and it's a very important one in much debated that at a critical time in the
battle.
One technique would be one side would give one great big shove,
the word in Greek is off,
says moss.
And if that was successful as it might be,
could knock down the lines of the front guys and get the other side running.
And there's an ancient evidence is an ancient source for that that says that's
what happened.
And that's one of the things that we have to deal with.
The critics of this point of view would say that's impossible and inconceivable.
Another possible explanation of the significance of depth is remember our poor
victim here.
If you multiply her,
then,
um,
you want to have as much depth to fill in behind to close that hole as you can
so that that would make your Phalanx more sturdy because you ha you could,
could take more casualties without breaking.
That seems reasonable to me.
Uh,
but again,
I,
I can't imagine how these guys fought in these circumstances.
I really can't see it.
I mean,
I,
it's a pity we can't kill people as in experiments deliberately anymore because
we need to see how this works.
But I'm,
I can't do it.
Um,
but I do think that that makes a reasonable amount of sense.
Anything else on are the mechanics of our failings?
Yes.
A little louder.
Please
charge each other.
Is that what you're saying?
Well,
what happens is it's usually,
well,
it's always the case.
One army is invading the land of the other.
So it's in a way it decides when the fighting is to take place up to a point.
Namely,
it's going to happen this summer cause we're coming and it's going to happen
this week.
It's going to happen tomorrow if you don't run away.
So now the defenders have to do in the perfect situation,
I am marching towards their corn crop grain crop at the time,
just before the grain is going to be harvested.
If we cut down that grain,
you don't eat this winter,
you get in front of the grain when we say so.
That would be the classic way of determining how it works.
It's never,
it probably wasn't quite that easy,
but that not the invading side goes for something that the other fella has to
defend.
And that determines when the fighting takes place.
Yes sir.
Hmm.
Hard to say.
Hard to imagine anybody doing this for more than a couple of hours.
So that would be my guess,
but nobody knows for sure.
But I think if you can imagine up to a couple of hours would be about right.
And that's worth mentioning.
How long has the war?
A couple of hours.
Because typically there's just one battle.
One side beats the other,
and that's the war for now until we get,
of course,
this is all early days until we get to the Peloponnesian war,
when things change radically in fighting in general.
But this is your standard.
Yes sir.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I could be that bad.
Well,
you got to realize that much of the time until the,
until the Phalanx breaks,
there's not a lot of killing that can go on.
You can only kill just,
you know,
just a few people while they're still defending themselves in this manner.
I have to believe that the bulk,
the bulk of the killing took place on the flight.
And so that's why that works out.
Yup.
What do you do the rest of the time?
Just
you,
you if you're not hitting your pushing,
that's the theory
or too or too,
yes.
How did they decide?
No,
that's right.
They would have decided on the basis of what was most effective and you
wouldn't,
you would not want old guys.
By the way,
how old are the people out there is a good question.
Typically the youngest guys were 20 typically the oldest guys are 45 but
everybody was liable to military service in the states till they were about 60
so you can imagine in certain circumstances there would be guys that old back
there,
but fundamentally it's between 20 and 45 okay.
I would have thought that the front row would exclude the older people.
You want tough guys upfront.
You don't want your front line being broken,
so the guys up front,
they're going to,
the younger you are,
chances are you're going to be more physically strong than older guys.
Probably though you wouldn't want to have the very youngest guys up front
because another thing you want is experience.
People who have seen this before,
done it before,
lived through it,
and now you can count on him not to run away better than you can on a fresh
recruiters.
Never done this before.
So if you,
I would have thought,
so you see,
I'm speculating to a certain degree,
but I would've thought you would've had guys 25 to 35 in the front couple of
three lines and then behind them,
younger men and then maybe the older men at the very back or maybe because she
wanted to be sure that that last row didn't turn and run away too fast.
You might have some who were not quite so old at the very back,
but it's all a question of what's effective and why.
That would be my thinking about that.
Yes.
In what they normally I say that a typical Phalanx is eight.
However,
by the time you get down to the fourth century and people are doing all kinds of
new and innovative things,
uh,
we hear that the left wing of the B ocean army at Luke Tra was 50 men deep.
Now,
what are you going to do with that?
But it's,
it's clearly a fat.
There were previous examples of people trying to have a deep wing that would,
uh,
would do things.
But if you take me back to my primitive Phalanx here,
about 600,
six 50,
they're not doing that stuff yet.
I would have guessed they were typically,
but,
but I think the depth would have been determined by how many soldiers you had
available.
You would have made your Phalanx as deep as you could.
And uh,
once you had the width established.
Yeah.
Yes ma'am.
The question is what would the defeat an army,
army kill all the defeated guys who were still on the battlefield at the time?
It would vary.
They could capture them.
There's an address,
there's a reason to capture them.
You could demand ransom for them.
So there would be some inclination to capture men rather than to kill him.
On the other hand,
guys who are engaged in a fight of the kind way must imagine get very angry at
these guys killed a buddy next to you.
So there would have been a certain amount of just furious killing going on,
but I don't think that would have been the way you,
you plan the game,
you,
you kill enough guys to achieve your goal and if you are still rational,
you'd take them.
The rest prisoner,
I think would be the way to go.
Yes.
Yes sir.
Yeah.
What would stop?
It would be,
yeah,
why didn't they flanked each other?
Boy,
if they could,
they would.
But the difficulty is if you take your left flank and move it out here so you
can flank this guy,
one of two things has to happen to your army.
Either you open a nice hole between yourself and the rest of your army,
which case somebody who's going to get very badly killed and you're going to be
on the run very soon,
or you have to somehow communicate to the rest of the army.
Everybody come over this way,
which will still leave that flank open to being flanked by the other side.
That's what prevents that from happening.
We just don't see that going on.
Yeah.
What was it?
Just the big sense of honor and propriety that kept them from doing like more
creative,
like sneak attack.
I,
I see it used to be thought that before,
but people were very careful.
We know that they do every terrible thing in the world,
in the Peloponnesian war,
that whatever the rules were before they're off.
When we get into the Peloponnesian war is just no dirty trick that anybody fails
to do if we can.
But,
uh,
they surely must have done it before to any,
you know,
when you're serious,
any way to win,
we'll,
we'll do.
But mostly you could make a virtue of necessity.
The kind of battle I've been describing to get a nice flat field,
two armies coming at each other.
There's not much you can do in the way of trickery.
And so you can take a high tone and say,
anybody who fights any other way is a no good coward.
In fact,
we have some claim in a Roman writer later on that there was a treaty back in
the eighth century BC between a couple of states in Euboea that said they would
never use,
uh,
you know,
missiles of any kind because that was cowardly.
The only legitimate fighting is man against man shield against shield,
chest against chest.
Everybody else has a pussy.
So I think,
uh,
that became an IPI and whatever the reality was,
that story was always being told.
That's the way for a man to fight.
Anything other than that is open to the suspicion.
Well,
okay.
Thank you very much.
Hoplites a little hand for our house,
right.
Um,
just a few more little details.
The,
um,
this situation begins that remember the two sides are opposite each other in the
field.
Probably in the morning.
Each side conducts sacrifices in which they ask the gods for assistance in the
battle.
Uh,
sometimes they hope that there'll be a favorable omen suggesting they're going
to win.
They have breakfast,
they drink and they advance typically to a battle song called a Pion,
uh,
which we have,
what they said,
what they sang.
I don't have the tune but I have the words and La,
la,
la low.
Does that sound like a good thing to march into?
That sounds good to me.
I like that.
And then would come to battle.
I talked to you about the pursuit,
the aftermath.
Here's just one more thing you need to know about.
This Phalanx modified
when the failings fought against
any other infantry formation.
The Phalanx wins until from the time we first hear of Greeks fighting non
Greeks.
When the Greeks have the Phalanx,
I think I'm right in saying they never lose a batter.
Finally they do in the,
I think it's the second century BC when King Philip of massive don has a his
phalanx fighting against the Roman Legion and the Legion wins.
But believe me,
it was no easy thing for the legion to win.
Even in that battle.
There's nothing automatic about that.
But,
and so,
so great was the military success of the Phalanx that the king of Persia who was
always getting into wars,
uh,
and hiring troops whenever the kings could,
they hired Greek hoplites to fight for them.
Uh,
when kings,
uh,
Prince Cyrus,
seeks to overthrow his brother right after the Peloponnesian war,
he signs up 10,000 veterans of the Peloponnesian War from the Peloponnesus
because with 10,000 Greek hoplites,
he believes that he can conquer the Persian empire and make himself king even
though the numbers are fabulous.
And those Greeks March,
1500 miles into the center of the Persian empire,
down at the Babylonia fight,
the army of the Persian king defeat the army of the Persian King.
But unfortunately,
the prince who led them down there is killed in the battle making the victory
rather pointless because the whole idea was to make an king.
And so then you have Xenophon riding his analysis,
the march back to telling the story of how those 1500,
uh,
those 10,000 Greeks rally got back home.
Um,
just a word for the other side of the argument.
I,
I went to read you a quotation from Hans von Vase,
who is the leading a critic of the traditional Orthodox explanation I just gave
you.
Here's one.
It is clear that the emergence of the hoplite was only the beginning of a
lengthy process,
which certainly lasted more than a century and may have lasted more than two
centuries leading to the creation of a close ordered hoplites only failings.
The classical hoplite formation then was not the long lived military institution
of scholarly tradition,
but merely one phase in a history of almost four centuries of slow change
towards ever denser and more cohesive,
heavy infantry for nations.
And I'll read you one more of his,
uh,
statements.
Those who favor an early date for the emergence of the hoplite Phalanx rely on
the arguments of blogging meant above all one argument above all,
the new type of shield adopted in the late eighth century,
unlike its predecessors,
could be used effectively only in an extremely close and rigid formation,
double grip shields,
thus presupposed or impose an extremely dense formation.
The tacit assumption is that how has that hoplites stood frontally opposed to
their enemies?
Like restless rather than sideways on like fencers holding their shields
parallel to their bodies.
But artistic representations show that this is not how hoplites fought.
I would say that the crux,
the kernel of the critique with a lot of things you can argue about,
the kernel of the critique lies in this assertion,
which derives its force from an interpretation of pictures on pottery.
You can see I'm not too friendly to that interpretation,
but it,
it is being taken very,
very seriously.
So seriously,
you fortunate Yalies that they will be here on April 9th and 10th of 1908 an
international conference on the subject of the hoplite Phalanx and the emergence
of the city state.
And it will be a classic Greek Akgonul confrontation because among the other
stars who are going to be an engaged Curtis eastern,
we'll be one of them.
Ah,
the main event will be a one on one between Victor Davis Hanson and Hans Fund
Vase.
You're all very welcome to come on that occasion.
See you next time.